so within the tech industry contrition
is in over the last 12 18 24 months this
industry that's been renowned for its
optimism about the future well that
started to shift we've now had a
creeping recognition I think that the
industry has started to go the wrong way
just as promised technologists have
moved fast and broken many things and
the founders and influencers within this
world who previously talked about
technology as almost an unalloyed good
in the world and now writing remorseful
medium posts they're forming nonprofits
to express their concern about the
direction that we've taken and they're
begging for a second chance there's now
an unprecedented focus and an overdue
focus frankly on the harms that
technology can do the press is as likely
to call technology a danger as it is at
Savior and that's understandable because
we keep serving up these easy examples
Microsoft a the racist chat bot
Facebook's emotional contagion study in
which they tried to change the mood of
six hundred and eighty nine thousand
people without consent Twitter with its
ongoing failing failings to grapple with
abuse on its platform and of course uber
which was for a long time its own
corporate soap opera of ethical
challenge shall we say and there's now
some effect some evidence that's having
an effect on how the public views the
tech industry doctor everyone who are a
think tank based in London they polled
the public on attitudes to technology
and they found that 50% of respondents
said that technology had made their
lives better
it's a pretty good number only 12%
however said the tech had a very
positive impact on society itself and so
for me that's a worrying trend because
over the next 10 15 20 years the
technology community is going to demand
an enormous amount of trust from its
users we're going to ask people to
connect more and more of their lives to
the products and the services that we
build we're going to ask them to trust
us with their homes their vehicles even
the safety of their families the
potential harms that are implied and
contained within emerging technology far
out do those even in today's technology
stakes will only get higher with time so
this has been my focus now for last two
or three years so in this talk today I'd
like to discuss and highlight the
ethical challenges inherent in today's
and tomorrow's technologies but then
also talk specifically about how we as
current and emerging future
practitioners can grapple with some of
those ethical challenges I'll start with
data ethics which have become you know a
fairly prominent case study if you like
for some of the challenges the industry
is facing something very interesting has
happened with data in the way that we
talk about data the language that we use
previously until maybe a couple of years
ago we used to use the language of the
library when we talked about data data
was cataloged stored it was referenced
it was queried but we no longer talk
about data in that way instead of new
metaphor has taken its place data is the
new oil and that's a revealing metaphor
in many ways it suggests that data is
something that we now burn for profit
and it suggests or it implies that data
has become an unstoppable natural force
a liquid a torrent a deluge it's no
accident of course that liquids have a
habit of leaking and no data has become
central to pretty much any technological
endeavor I think sometimes it's tempting
to over focus on the advertising use
case the data there's a lot of discourse
that centers on the ethics of
advertising in technology and the data
requirements of that but any company has
really now incentivized to gather
information on use and on their users
analytics
is critical to most companies now to
understand how their products and
services are having an effect in the
marketplace how they're changing
behaviors and of course data is
particularly useful for artificial
intelligence for training without AI
there simply is no without data rather
there simply is no AI and so companies
authorities governments are like in our
incentivized to create vast reserves of
data on the habits of the citizens and
users within their systems
and to an extent those communities of
citizens and consumers are themselves
now interchangeable under the right
legal and technical circumstances data
available to a company will also be made
available to a government autonomous
vehicles for an example will give will
create up to something like four
terabytes of data a day a vast amount of
data from these mobile clusters of
sensors and cameras and lidar that they
that they will have this data will be of
course invaluable to the manufacturers
the software companies behind these
vehicles so they can understand are they
operating correctly and how can they be
tweaked to work more efficiently but
this same data will also be invaluable
to the police to investigate road
traffic accidents and potentially all
sorts of crimes on the street that have
nothing to do with road traffic
accidents themselves this increase of
power that comes with having these
mobile sensory apparatuses prompted the
Economist magazine who are hardly
opponents of corporate power of
technological progress to label
autonomous vehicles panopticon's on
wheels a lot of the ethical impact I
think that surrounds data comes from its
invisibility and also stems from kind of
some of the attitudes and the precepts
that we believe in as designers as
people following the ideas of user
centricity the famous book by Steve Krug
called don't make me think really talks
about the idea of treating some things
as complexity that's best hidden from
the user and I think data is one of them
designers have chosen to treat data
flows as something that shouldn't really
be seen by user that don't need to be
exposed we've decided that users have no
business really appearing under the hood
to see what's happening within these
systems and so we have now a perfect
storm I think where we have a host of
new sensors in our urban environments
and within our devices we have data
pouring invisibly between these
cooperating systems and we have
companies and authorities incentivize to
gather as much as they can
is therefore a potential breeding ground
for unethical behavior data of course
then fuels algorithms algorithmic bias
has become over the last couple of years
a much more familiar topic than it has
in the past largely thanks to Pro
Publica cos investigation into the
compass crime prediction algorithm which
found that or claimed that black people
would be more likely to be future
offenders than white people but we've
known about algorithmic bias since the
1980s a medical school in the United
Kingdom built an algorithm to process
job applications and eventually found
that it was biased against women and
people with non-european sounding names
this was quite a big deal at the time I
think the British Medical Journal ended
up publishing a piece of adding and
calling it a blot on the profession and
yet it's only recently that we've almost
rediscovered this as a community the
idea of algorithmic bias can be quite
tough to tackle within tech firms
because there's a perception that
algorithms are clean and objective and
neutral but of course that's not the
case professor Jeffrey Boca coined a a
memorable phrase raw data is an oxymoron
all data and all algorithms carry the
implicit bias of the people and the
cultures that make them you can't
separate data from its means of
collection and presentation you can't
separate analytical algorithms from
their processes and their manufactures
and the systems that they use here we
see as a graphic a tremendous piece of
information design I think by a chap
called Simon scar this is for the South
China Morning Post and clearly it
depicts the impacts of the Iraq conflict
and scar has chosen a very obvious
metaphor a leading metaphor a biasing
metaphor intentionally to bring home the
scale of the conflict
obviously the metaphor here you know
literally or metaphorically drips from
the page on the right now we see Andy
graves attempt to change the
meaning of this data with the same the
very same raw data but by making simply
three changes by changing the hue
by changing the headline and then
inverting it on the y-axis I suppose it
would be cop grave completely reverses
the meaning of the same data set
meanwhile algorithms are being
increasingly entwined in critical human
decisions sentencing jobs hiring firing
promotions access to public services and
so on the smart city itself is
predicated upon the idea of sensing
what's happening within our environments
and then using though that data to fuel
algorithms to respond we have things
like ShotSpotter used in the u.s. to
listen for gunfire within urban centers
we have facial recognition technology
which is increasing in power each year
within a couple of years perhaps will be
possibly used to track people's
movements through an entire city and to
also find out their personal
associations who do they hang out with
the most in what areas so combine this
deep data harvesting with unquestioned
and opaque algorithmic decisions and you
have in the words of Zeynep to fetch key
to building blocks of authoritarianism
technologies are also powerfully
persuasive all technologies are
persuasive but sometimes that's become
an explicit focus of the industry mostly
this centers on the idea of nudging
people towards healthier living you know
we have fitbit's that try to motivate us
to go out and take the active life we
have health health apps diet tracking
apps and so on that will try and tempt
us away from the burger and toward the
salad but of course there are other uses
other uses for all of these persuasive
potentials if you like and so we have
what's bordering on a moral panic right
now about addictive technology
technology that has trained the users to
keep coming back for more
now it's my understanding I don't think
tech addiction and social media
addiction is actually yet evidenced as a
separate disorder but it's clear that
there is some particularly trashy use of
technology out there that's resulted
from this persuasive mentality this
chasing of certain engagement metrics
but the greater concern for me is what
comes next
Karen Young who's a legal scholar in
London she talks about a persuasive
system that is dynamic able to change
its approaches based on what works and
what doesn't for you
it's Network so it can learn not only
from you but from millions of other
persuasive subjects and it's deeply
personalized so it has access to the
data that we've discussed previously and
so it knows which buttons it push it can
push within you that system a hyper
nudge system as young calls it could be
an irresistible force of manipulation
and so this suggests some quite deep
ethical questions at what point for
example does a nudge become a shove when
does this start to undermine our free
will our autonomy and again if this
happens invisibly doesn't that create
some kind of power imbalance will people
be able to recognize that this is
happening
can they collectivise against it can
they protest will they understand who's
trying to manipulate their behavior for
what ends we also have I think some
significant challenges around the ethics
of sustainability and the environmental
impact of our work Viktor papinek who
was an industrial designer wrote a book
called design for the real world
and it opens with this memorable line
which of course I now have to remember
there are professions more harmful than
Industrial Design but only a very few of
them it's a great line but when I say it
to digital people they're people working
in software and tech a lot of the time I
get a response saying oh it's it's
powerful but we're off the hook K right
we're not the ones wrapping things in
plastic and piling them high and selling
them cheap to which my response is we
should look at say what happens with the
Volkswagen scandal their emissions
scandal was a pure software cheat within
the existing architecture of the engine
they simply put a software hack in to
cheat emissions tests
creating undeclared emissions that will
kill by some estimates hundreds of
people increasingly every device is
tending toward having a chip in it some
kind of smart
sensor array so of course there's this
hybridization for physical and digital
worlds software is very much heating the
world crypto mining for instance a
Bitcoin network now uses well I've been
tracking energy use of this for a little
while it was using the same amount of
energy of Paraguay and it was Iceland
it's now Austria currently uses 0.33
percent of all electricity in the world
and the upgrade cycles of consumer tech
are enormous ly aggressive think of all
the handsets or tablets or laptops that
you've owned even the last five to ten
years where are they now do you still
have them all what's happened with the
rare earth minerals that were mined to
create the LCDs the gyroscopes the
sensors within these systems helen
walters is a design critic and writer
and she reviewed the CES electronic show
of 2011 i think it was and she pointed
out that she talked a lot of designers
who espoused the idea of sustainable
innovation yes at CES there were 20,000
new products unveiled including 80
tablets the Walter says well this isn't
sustainable
nor is it innovation it's vandalism I'll
be comfortable with our roles in this
change do we want to be these agents for
obsolescence that we are becoming I
think we also have some tricky ethical
questions to ask when we enter an era of
machine autonomy some of our deepest
held principles and processes
particularly the idea of user centricity
and user centered design start to go
away because these technologies aren't
about use anymore it's really about
coexistence the ethics of automation
often bring up this hoary old topic of
the trolley problem which I'm sure most
of you are familiar with you know the
drill by now a thought experiment from
philosophy from Philippa foot I think in
1967 perhaps do you pull a switch to
redirect a runaway trolley to kill two
people rather than three workers on the
tracks do you push a fat man off the
tracks to stop the trolley in the first
place and it's you know as a fault
experiment it's fairly well known but
the theory goes that it
more real becomes rarefied in the world
of autonomous vehicles MIT run a study
which they called moral machine
essentially crowdsourcing reactions so
this trying to understand how the
general public thought an autonomous
vehicle should react in there's life of
life or death cases but to be honest
it's something of a red herring
Andrew Chatham who is a lead engineer on
the way Moe project says you know it
takes the intrigue out of the problem
but the answer is you slam on the brakes
so for me the trolley problem actually
masks some deeper and more interesting
moral challenges how do we handle the
dilution of responsibility that tenon
technologies bring us if one of these
machines hits a cyclist for example we
might look at whether the cyclists you
know rode out with without due care or
attention we might ask whether their
software was poorly programmed or
malfunctioning perhaps the driver still
bought some responsibility in if it was
a semi autonomous vehicle do we have to
reconfigure our views of liability for
instance of these systems should we at
some point choose to disable a vehicle
if the user has chosen not to apply a
firmware update the moral machine study
I mentioned found essentially that the
general public wants to harm as few
people as possible with these systems
they wanted systems that were governed
by what's called utilitarian lens which
we'll come on to shortly but subsequent
to that a paper in science from jean
francois bon for actually found that no
one wanted to buy those systems everyone
liked the idea of a utilitarian vehicle
that would minimize harm unless they
were potentially the person at risk of
harm so there's an open question here
where people actually want these truly
moral machines if it has an impact on
their own safety Mercedes for example
have already announced that in this
situation this theoretical decision of
whether to harm a pedestrian or the
driver
they will always harm the pedestrian
they will protect the driver at all
costs may not be that big a surprise
coming from a company like Mercedes but
I can actually understand it in terms of
that that's the decision that they've
taken to protect the one person that
they have them
to control over and then of course there
are questions about what we shouldn't
automate in 2016 the Dallas police
killed a suspect Michael Xavier Johnson
ironically by rigging a bomb defusal
robots with c4 explosive and they
piloted it over to him and blew him up
in this in this siege now that was a
drone that wasn't an autonomous system
it was piloted remotely as I say but
autonomy is going to creep into these
systems we have militaries all over the
world now interested in lethal
autonomous weapon systems and even if
you're not directly working on those
projects as a technologist a lot of the
AI work that we do can be used for
military purposes so there are deep
questions about where technologists
choose to draw the line and of course
there are significant potential impacts
on the world of work we're on the brink
of the fourth Industrial Revolution this
was news to me I'm no historian I
thought we were done with one but what
happened in those previous revolutions
of course was that the world of work and
manufacturing was transformed but it
ended up in a stable steady state the
number of people in work remained
roughly the same after each of the
previous three that may not hold this
time because the main difference here is
this is no longer about physical
automation but cognitive automation any
job no matter its current status within
the marketplace if you like can be
decomposed into tasks many of which will
be automatable so it's possible we'll
end up with a deeply two-tier world of
work where we have jobs essentially
above and below the API the middle gets
hollowed eight and we have a small
number of people who are able to command
the machines who instruct and test and
check the machines and then we have a
much larger group of people in
precarious positions in low paid low
status positions who are essentially
working lifting assembling carrying at
the behest of the algorithm in that
two-tier society that could clearly
deepen inequality the influence of
capital as opposed to labor will only
grow in that system unless we take some
checks against it
if you own the means of production while
that's enormous ly potent if you have
the ability to produce pretty much
anything so there are all sorts of deep
questions about sort of future and the
sort of economies that we want in a
world of cognitive automation I think
the nightmare the dystopia is we end up
in a world that's not yet post-work but
is fully post worker we expect people to
still be paying their mortgage and
working and being salaried individuals
but we simply cannot perform as well as
the machines and then finally of course
there are the sexy sci-fi questions
about what happens when artificial
intelligence reaches some kind of
comparable human level do or will robots
at some point deserve moral and legal
rights of their own should we ascribe
legal and moral personhood to artificial
agents if we do then we have to consider
reconsider perhaps the the very idea of
ownership we have laws against owning
people that's something we call slavery
will machines ever have consciousness is
it ethical to build anthropomorphic
machines as that set up a false
expectation of the capabilities of these
systems and of course that utterly
seductive question will they kill us all
now I think these are fascinating topics
and they cause they come up a lot but
I'm actually not going to focus on them
here I think it's very easy to be
distracted by these distant sci-fi
threats to the expense of the more
pressing issues in front of us today I
think what powerful and intelligent
people do with technology is probably
more of a danger than powerful
intelligent technology so for me it's
clear that there's fertile ethical
ground for us to take these decisions
seriously to recognize the moral impacts
of our work that may sometimes be an
unpopular message of course within
industry you know it can be seen as a
drag on innovation it can be seen as
something needless and wasteful we just
want to push the pedal of progress I
suppose but I quite like the phrasing
from Peter Bava Bakke he's a philosopher
of Technology in the Netherlands
he says that ethics should accompany
technological progress it doesn't have
to necessarily oppose it we can find
ways to infuse it into our work as a
designer I like thinking of ethics as
our constraint now I know as a designer
that constraints sure they do reduce
some options but they also generate new
options ethics can be a seed of
innovation not just a pair of shears if
that's going to happen we have to come
to the overdue realization that
technology isn't neutral and frankly
that never was in 1980 Langdon winner
philosopher wrote a paper called do
artifact have politics and his
conclusion was well yeah damn right they
do he gave the example of Robert Moses
Robert Moses with a city planner of New
York you know I think the 20s and 30s
and Moses was a racist we have ample
evidence of his racist views and it's
alleged that it's a slightly disputed
account but it's alleged that he built
bridges over the parkways toward Long
Island beaches so low that buses
couldn't travel beneath them minorities
living in the city particularly black
residents tended to travel more
frequently by bus so essentially Moses
had tried to racially segregated
hulking great big structures these inert
hundreds of tons of steel and concrete
so if even a bridge can have moral
impact and of course a technology can
because it's a mistake to separate the
capabilities of technologies and of
humans we act together as in two oven
actors things change what people can do
and how we do them it is true to an
extent that guns don't kill people but
they sure as hell make it a lot easier
for people to kill people so we have to
get past this belief in neutrality this
belief that we can therefore wash our
hands of the social and political and
ethical responsibilities of our work I'd
go further and I'd say design is applied
ethics and sometimes that's a you know
there's a fairly obvious relationship
here if you design razor wire whether
you realize it or not you're making a
statement that people's right to person
private property is so important that we
should injure someone who chooses to
contravene that right but even if you're
not not making something so morally
Laden as razor wire or weapons all acts
of design involve making statements
about the future whenever you design
you're making a claim for how we should
live how we should interact with
technology in years to come and at the
same time you're also discarding tens of
thousands of alternative futures there's
a clear moral case within that in making
a statement about how we should live as
a society sadly I think the industry
tends to try to fall back on simple
answers well just don't work for whoever
your particular bete noire is that that
week or just ban ad funded technology or
perhaps we just need some kind of
Hippocratic oath for design or for
technology I'm particularly critical of
that last one I would say if another
code of ethics is the answer why haven't
the previous 20 worked but for me
probably the most important message is
that we aren't the first on these shores
technologists often like to believe
slightly arrogantly that we are beta
testing this ideal future we're the ones
trying to grapple with these deep issues
for the first time but of course there
are millennia of histories and of
insight into morality ethics as a topic
there are decades of work in science and
technology studies in philosophy of
technology so we have contemporary
academics critical designers
philosophers artists writers have been
grappling with these questions for far
longer frankly than we have and they've
done this fascinating deep work but
sadly they haven't really been taken
that seriously within industry I think
the tech industry is deeply intelligent
but it's it's strongly anti intellectual
and I think it's time for that to change
we need to start learning from the
academics and artists and thinkers
who've grappled with these topics and
then bring them into our own work
ultimately the success stages we want
ethics to become an ethos a way that we
approach our work and
world but we also have to recognize that
we need to take some concrete steps I'm
a little bit wary to suggest that ethics
is something we should sort of inject
into our process nevertheless I'm going
to focus on a few particular points in
the design and product development
process that we can focus on so this is
my oversimplification over the design
process anyone who's a designer here
forgive me for this oversimplification
we know that it's rather messier than
this but I think we can start right at
the beginning of any project definition
when we're kicking off projects we have
to consider things like who are the
stakeholders that are part of our remit
now if you look at say business
textbooks they'll talk a lot about
stakeholder analysis but they'll often
focus on really just one category of
stakeholders people who can affect the
project but of course there is a second
class that often goes unheard people
whom the project can affect and I think
we've often overlooked these people in
the name of user centered design we
focused very much on trying to fulfill
the needs of the primary persona the
user whoever that may be
Airbnb I think is a good example of this
Airbnb is a very well designed product
or service
whichever you call it for two groups of
people for people who have property they
wish to rent out and people who are in a
different City and want to rent a room
or an apartment or something like that
it's a very well designed system for
those folks
unfortunately the costs of the system
are paid by the local community if you
live next door to an Airbnb rental you
no longer have a neighbor you have a new
series of neighbors every couple of days
dragging their damned wheels roller
wields bag bags over the cobbles at 4
a.m. that kind of stuff they're not
gonna spend their money locally they'll
spend it in the tourist traps they're
not interested in living by the norms of
your block or your neighborhood they
will live by their own sets of rules and
so this individualistic focused is quite
narrow focus on serving the needs of the
user has caused us to overlook broader
society's broader ecologies so we can we
can attack this in a couple of ways one
of the things I have started doing is
actually so
offering a prompt list saying should we
consider a broader set of people as
somehow implicated in our work there
might even be scoped to add abstract
concepts within this list I would say
for instance Facebook have found
recently that their work has started to
have an impact on it started to pick at
the seams of democracy or the freedom of
the press maybe these things need to be
regarded as stakeholders within our
systems I also like the idea of using
what I call a persona non-grata this is
a really simple thing it's essentially
an anti persona a dark persona a persona
noir if you like this is a bad actor
within our system and we choose some way
to expose them within the design studio
within the project team and of course
our job here is to hamper this person so
we'll find out what are their
motivations what are their goals on our
platform and how do we work hard to
dampen those to contradict them
I'm also increasingly interested in the
idea of what's called bias bracketing
this was something was fairly new to me
something that's apparently now become
quite common in social sciences research
the idea of trying to explicitly list in
advance all the ways in which bias might
impact future research that you're about
to undertake and by doing so you then
also create notes as the research goes
at any moment you suspect bias could
have an impact on your work and then you
can use that checklist essentially to
evaluate your results to say is it
possible that these existing sources of
bias have caused me to come to the wrong
conclusions I'd like to see the tech
industry do more of this kind of thing
when it comes to the ideas generation
phase of design and particularly looking
at the ethical implications we need to
rely on what's called moral imagination
this within ethics is probably a fairly
self-explanatory idea you have to
imagine different futures and try to
interpret what the moral impacts the
ethical impacts might be the difficulty
is that's pretty abstract it's kind of a
thought experiment so I like the idea
and I've seen good success in teams and
I trying to create something more
tangible
to provoke that conversation something
that I call a provocative now this is
easiest if I show an example of this
this is a great piece of design done by
muscle show and are in harm Van Beek for
two Dutch Energy clients and the
scenario that they've been asked to
illustrate with this provocative is a
scarce energy future which is highly
likely a future of electric vehicles and
public charging points also highly
likely and the question is how would a
system allocate these scarce resources
where there's more demand than there is
supply so they built this provocative
and it's you know it's a large it's a
large machine and it comes with these
plugs at the bottom they are actually
included that you know charging points
within the provocate Ike and so you pick
one up you plug it in into a free socket
you then have an ID card which you tap
on the reader above it to authenticate
to ID yourself with a system and then
you use the dials above it to request
more or less energy or later or sooner
or whatever it may be and the system the
algorithm does the rest so above it you
see a display of essentially how the
algorithm has concluded it will
apportion the energy over the coming
hours so we start right at the bottom
blue and red are being charged later on
blue will get the whole lot after that
its greens turn so we're moving up as
time goes on you'll also see on the
fringes there with the dot display
sometimes there's less energy bandwidth
if you like and sometimes there's plenty
of it that's to illustrate essentially
the differing amount of energy that's
going to be available at certain points
of the day so this system essentially
exposes what an algorithmically driven
decision might look like in the
practical world but the most interesting
part about this for me as they prototype
the ID cards as well the thing you tap
to authenticate with the system so these
cards that we see here they allocate
different social status and different
energy status so we have a doctor in the
middle as a doctor you have top priority
within this system however there's a
caveat rather than in red it says you
know misuse will be punished by law so
there's some kind of legal threat that
goes with it underneath that we have a
probation ID this is presumably for a
a recent offender their energy use is
capped it's the lowest priority of the
lot so we see how social status and
potential inequality becomes encoded and
reinforced through the IOT and through
energy scarcity now the designers aren't
proposing this as the best solution
they're not saying this is what public
charging infrastructure should
necessarily look like they're using this
provocative as I call it to provoke the
conversations that matter it's an
artifact that almost creates this
strange wormhole between design and
research so I think this kind of work is
terrifically important to stimulate that
moral imagination so that we can make
more informed decisions but of course it
takes time we need to have the time in
the space for this divergence to happen
something that tech companies don't
always provide so I think we need to
start pushing for it as part of our
natural process within the design phase
itself as I've mentioned a lot of the
ethical challenges in tech come from the
invisibility that it often has whether
it's intentional or otherwise and so I
think as a an important opportunity to
shift data flows persuasion things like
that into the visible spectrum so that
people can make more informed decisions
probably the best example in consumer
product is is this is there the Prius
energy monitor I'm sure some of you
recognize it I think this is quite an
old version I think this is fantastic
design because what it does is it helps
to depict this abstract concept energy
flow within a vehicle this complex
system nicely simplified through design
but it allows the driver to change their
driving style and their habits to get
the best out of a system to hopefully
get it to act in a way that conserves
energy or that responds in a more
perfectly responsible way perhaps
so by materializing the previously
invisible this flow of energy within a
system people can act in more
sustainable ways
here's my example of how this might look
for say a hypothetical home hub if I've
got something like you know like a bit
like a nest or the iOS home app or
perhaps is that the echo look or echo
show I never remember which that the
echo that can link your home your home
network together let's say we have a
system that gathers data about your
habits who are viewing biometrics and so
on with consent let's say and passes
some of it to advertisers in exchange
for this being a cheap product or free
or something like that this is my
attempt to depict how we could have a
similar overview of the data flows
within that system so this allows for
informed consent of what's happening it
also allows for correction if I say well
I actually don't want you to have this
information I'm assuming we can I tap on
this and swipe it away and say actually
be gone we're going to break that
connection there so I think this is a
step toward more informed consent and
more informal exchange of data for
valuable technology I think we also need
to take steps towards occasionally
increasing the friction making
technologies that no longer recede into
the background but actually intervene in
people's experiences and almost get in
the way sometimes making me think so
here's again a hypothetical as a modal
interface for the same home hub and it's
asking for some very personal data
I think heartrate location I think that
is a decision the user shouldn't be
taking lightly
I think the user also should be informed
that any data even if it's de-identified
or if it's anonymized
there's always a risk that in future
that can be unpicked with different data
sets to correlate or different
algorithms to process that data so the
user should be informed of that risk and
I'm choosing here to contradict some
fundamental user experience principles
by making it more difficult to say yes
so I'm actually insisting that the user
takes a stylus or their finger and
actually writes the words I agree with
in this interface I think there's also
ethical theory that we can draw upon one
of these one of these ideas is what's
called the veil of ignorance this comes
from the philosopher John Rawls who
wrote a book a theory of justice
and the idea of the veil of ignorance is
essentially the fairest system is one
designed as if we are behind this veil
not knowing an ultimate place within the
system so let's say I'm designing a
welfare system a fair welfare system
would be one that no matter what hand I
was dealt whether I was a welfare
recipient an administrator of the scheme
or a taxpayer that I would regard the
system as fair so this might be a useful
technique when designing technological
systems as well designing them as if we
could be put in any number of positions
within that ecosystem critique is
obviously a terribly important part of
the process when it comes to discussing
our ethical responsibilities I think a
healthy critique process is a large part
of the battle one one thing we can do
here is to employ what's sometimes
called a designated dissenter this is an
idea that comes from Eric Meyer and
sarawak de Bechet they wrote a book
called design for real life and this
role is essentially a role of
constructive antagonism someone whose
job it is to kind of lobby in a grenade
of defiance every now and then and say
what if I don't want to provide the
information you're requesting what if
I'm going through an emotionally
difficult time for example you're asking
for my marital status and I'm going
through a messy breakup or a divorce how
dare you ask for this information so
it's this role to challenge and subvert
some of the assumptions that a tech team
has made now what to better admire
suggests and I agree that this role
needs to be rotated right you don't want
how you don't have someone doing this
for an entire year and start to sour
their perceptions and they'll start to
get rather ignored but I think it's a
powerful way to introduce those
constructive challenges into the design
process I also think there's an
opportunity here to draw on a little bit
more ethical Theory something I call the
for ethical tests and my attempt here is
to try and draw on the three main
schools of modern ethics and translate
them into practical questions
the tech teams can ask sums asked
themselves so this is about as
theoretical as I'll get so please
with me the first question I'll suggest
is what if everyone did what I am about
to do would a world in which this
decision or this law of behavior if you
like where that was universal would that
be a better place or a workplace and
this comes from Immanuel Kant this is
what's known in ethics as a de
ontological view on ethics a down't
ologist is someone who believes in
what's morally right to do there are
certain laws that should govern our
behavior people have certain rights for
instance so let's have a look at this
question in the context of a dark
pattern the deceptive interface I've got
someone on my team trying to persuade me
to ship a dark pattern well I can ask
this question if we all put deceptive
interfaces in our products then the
sphere of technology is diminished in
fact probably our lives without little
bit worse so according to this question
I don't think that's a healthy world and
that's something that I'm going to
reject also from Kant another question
that he poses essentially comes down to
am i treating people as ends or as means
this takes maybe a little bit of
unpacking in the world of technology and
design this is mostly about our users
are we treating them as means for me to
hit my own targets or am i treating them
as a free individual with their own
goals which are perhaps more important
than my own this is a question I think
that most individuals don't really have
a problem with we all recognize the idea
of users as independent autonomous
people but I find in some large se
data-driven organizations this is a
question that starts to get a little bit
more challenging because in these
organizations sometimes the way we see
users shifts subtly with time they
become not the res on debt or not the
reason that we're here but they become
means for us to hit our own targets
essentially people become masses and
when that happens on ethical design is I
think the natural result the third
ethical test that I can offer is what's
known as utilitarian perspective on
ethics am i maximizing happiness for the
greatest number of people and by
extension and by minimizing suffering
minimize
harm and this utilitarian question is is
really about the impact the consequences
of our decisions so utilitarian doesn't
really care so much about the morally
correct way to behave they're not going
to draw up a list of of moral rules
instead they'll look at what the actual
consequence is the impact of their
choices is now this to the tech industry
is often seen quite as a promising
Avenue because this feels slightly
measurable right I can put people in
brain scanners I can do the galvanic
skin response stuff I can get their Net
Promoter scores I can see their eventual
behaviors on our platforms so this feels
slightly appealing but it also has some
downsides as a way of thinking about
morality are we really expected to do
this for every single decision does this
not turn us into number crunchers rather
than living breathing people and it also
struggles with what's sometimes called
the tyranny of the majority if I have a
population 99 percent of whom want to
exile or execute a one percent minority
if I mean unit utilitarian that can be a
a slightly hard thing to to combat with
this lens the fourth and final ethical
test I'll offer is grounded in the final
score the third school of modern ethics
which is called virtue ethics and the
question is would I be happy for this to
be a front-page story the virtue
ethicists don't care so much about rules
or outcomes unlike their dermatological
and utilitarian counterparts they're
really interested in moral character
what does this say about me as an
individual what values what virtues am i
trying to live by so this question
really for me is about accountability is
this a decision that I'm happy to sign
my name to would it be okay if it was a
push notification sent to all my friends
and family and the Dame side I think of
this way of thinking though is you're
really acting only out of a fear of
embarrassment this is you know I'm not
behaving in a certain way because other
people might criticize my character say
I'm a bad person for doing it that feels
like fairly shaky grounds for proper
moral behavior
finally of course there is a role for
for testing / checking the work that
we've done and seeing whether it
actually has the effects that we're
hoping it does Kate Crawford who's an
academic and also works with Microsoft
Research talks about fairness forensics
as a an excellent talk at the ni PS
conference which you might want to look
up and it's a system of approaches that
can be used to try and interrogate the
bias that's maybe sits within our data
within our systems within our algorithms
and to try and mitigate that bias where
possible but I'm also a huge fan of
trying to pair these analytical
approaches with more qualitative
approaches conducting deep research with
perhaps some of the most vulnerable
groups within our systems as I mentioned
at the start Tech and humanity tend to
sort of interweave so unfortunately it
often happens that the hardens of
Technology fall upon society's most
vulnerable groups anyway so I think
teams have a duty to talk to these
people to reach out to activists from
these groups and also very carefully to
talk with people who have undergone
these harms who have experienced them
for themselves understanding their lived
experiences and trying to negotiate
their needs better within that system
underpinning it all is an idea that I
would call ethical infrastructure trying
to build a company's capability and
resilience for emotional sorry for
ethical questions one important step I
think is to hire diverse teams diverse
teams really are a kind of an ethical
early warning system if you like I've
been in conversations where
representatives who are from different
groups different backgrounds different
experiences than other people on the
team have raised the hand and said well
do you realize that the decision we're
about to take is actually going to have
this effect for this group of people and
of course no they didn't realize that so
the interplay between people with
inherent and acquired diversity the the
mix that we can bring to the table I
think builds our capabilities to
anticipate these emotional these ethic
or harms I think it's important for
leaders within the tech industry to
recognize right behaviors moral
behaviors and try to reward them make
sure that career ladders for instance
actually talk about what is the ethical
behavior we expect of someone moving
into management say or someone moving
into a senior position how should they
behave and then using those criteria to
assess promotion hiring even firing
decisions rewarding the right behaviors
not just the right results one way to
help concretize that is to create a
system of core values for the
organization to say this is what we
believe as a company this is how we
essentially resolve ethical quandary zwi
can refer back to our agreed set of
values and use those as a guiding star
for our decisions but of course
ultimately the responsibility is
something we have to take on as
individuals as technologists as
practitioners I think morality isn't
some gift I don't think it's a natural
trait I think it's a muscle that needs
exercise I think we have to when the
time is right ask yourself ask ourselves
uncomfortable difficult questions how
might I be screwing up right now in my
work what's my preferred way of looking
at ethics referring back Saves of the
three ethical lenses and the for ethical
tests that I mentioned what my limit be
where would I draw the line and say I'm
not prepared to go past this and then
how would I handle that how would I have
that conversation with my teammates with
my manager ultimately if it's safe to do
so I think the choice to live a more
ethical life is about increasing the
risk that we bear individually now
that's a privileged position I recognize
not everyone has that safety and comfort
to be able to stand up for what they
believe to be right I don't think we
should judge others too harshly for
failing to do that we don't know their
individual circumstances but I would say
if you feel comfortable and safe and
respected in your positions or future
positions as
technologists as designers then you are
in a perfect position to use up a little
bit of that goodwill to stand up for
what you believe to be the morally
correct thing to do and that act of
standing up that act of disobedience
doesn't need to be purely obstinate and
aggressive there can be a role for that
but there are also more gentle ways to
subvert some of these decisions to say
I'm not entirely comfortable with the
way this is heading have we considered
using ethics as as I say a constraint as
a seed of innovation and trying an
alternative approach I also think just
to close out that this journey requires
patience it requires forgiveness to be
honest on ourselves as well self-care is
important on this journey the choice to
try and take ethics more seriously I can
tell you from experience not necessarily
a happy one not necessarily an easy one
it can be difficult it can be
emotionally draining at times it becomes
quite easy to punish yourself for the
mistakes that you make just as much as
you are a critic of others the good news
is I think choosing to take these
decisions seriously will also help you
get a bit closer to the kind of person
that you want to become for that it's
terrifically important we also draw from
each other given the challenges of the
future and all the ways that we could go
wrong with merging technology I think
we're gonna need all the thoughtful
technologists that we can get people who
care enough to make a difference in this
crucial industry and to navigate
together toward better futures I really
dearly hope that of course you will
choose to be one of those people thanks
for your time
you